🎵Music play🎵
Welcome to week two of six week renew groundwork session. So we're gonna start
on the lunge. This horse is very quiet on the lunge so it is in a halter. It's
also very sensitive on its face to my aides and cues so if your horse is
anything less than that then it's a good idea to do this exercise or these
exercises in a bridle and if your horse is very distracted then also with
side reins and a surcingle so that they can remain straight and do a little bit
more focused work. This horse is very focused on its own. So already what we
want to get from this exercise is being able to control the horse's step with
your breath. So as I inhale there she opens her step in the walk and makes it
bigger and as I come closer smaller with my body she's gonna make it smaller. So
both my arms are representing that being very obvious with the step. Making sure
that you're going both ways I like to switch at the walk, switch at the trot
and switch at the canter as opposed to doing all walk trot canter one direction
and then changing direction. I like to give them a well-rounded warm-up or just
integrate into the exercise. So in order to track how large the horse's step is
you watch where the front foot is falling and the hind foot is going to
either step into it behind it or in front of it. So we have two views here
one is going to be your view in the trot from the center of the circle and as you
can see when I open my body and get bigger and wider with my body she's
going to open her step up and when I get smaller with my body she's going to
close her step so making it shorter. So in order to get this task accomplished
with the horses you have to be very sensitive in your person and make them
attentive. So as you can see there as we zoom in my body is getting smaller there
arms are coming closer to the body chest is coming narrower and the step is
getting smaller and as I raise up bigger and wider even the whip can raise if you
need to opening the body then the step opens up. The same exercise in the canter
as in the walk and the trot as you open your body and make it bigger the horse
is going to have a step bigger and as you close your body and make it smaller
or hold the contraction then they're going to make their steps smaller. So
like I said this is the most attentive horse. If your horse is less attentive
then it's important to make your aids more clear and more obvious to them so
they can learn it. And you may need to correct them if they have limited
lunging abilities.
So there you can really see how the opening of the body is very obvious.
When we get to this view you can see the step clearly getting bigger and then
smaller and then bigger by the way she holds her back and the physical length
of her step.